The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's start.
So last lecture we started
on the topic of doing
renormalization
in position space.
And the idea, let's say,
was to look at something
like the Ising model, whose
partition function is obtained,
if you have insides, by
summing over all the 2 to the n
configuration of a weight
that tends to align variables,
binary variables that
are next to each other.
And this next to each
other is indicated
by this nearest neighbor
symbol, sigma i, sigma j.
Potentially, we may want
to add the magnetic field
like term that [INAUDIBLE].
The idea of the
renormalization group
is to obtain a similar
Hamiltonian that
describes interactions among
spins that are further apart.
We saw that we
could do this easily
in the case of the
one-dimensional system.
Well, let's say you have a line,
and you have sites on the line.
Each one of them wants to
make their neighbor parallel
to itself.
And what we saw was
that I could easily
get rid of every other spin
and keep one set of spins.
If I do it that, I get
a partition function
that operates between
the remaining spins.
Was very easy to sum over the
two variables that spin in
between these two
could have and conclude
that after this step, which
corresponds to removing half
of the degrees of freedom, I
get a new interaction, k prime,
which was 1/2 log hyperbolic
cosine of 2K, if h was zero.
And we saw that
that, which is also
a prototype of other
systems in one dimension,
basically is incapable of giving
you long-range order or phase
transition at finite temperature
that corresponds to finite k.
So the only place where you
could have potentially ordering
over large landscape
is when k becomes
very large at zero temperature.
We saw how the correlation
length behaves and diverges
as you approach zero temperature
in this type of model.
Now, the next step
would be to look
at something that
is two-dimensional.
And in this context,
I describe how
it would be ideal if, let's say,
we start with a square lattice.
We have interactions
k between neighbors.
And we could potentially
do the same thing.
Let's say remove one
sublattice of spins,
getting interactions among the
other sublattice of spins that
would again
correspond to removing
half of the spins in the system.
But in terms of
length scale change,
it corresponds to
square root of 2.
This length compared
to the old length
is different by a factor
of square root of 2.
But the thing that
I also indicated
was that this spin is now
coupled to all four of them.
And once I remove the spin, I
can generate new interactions
operating between these spins.
In fact, you will generate
also a four-spin interaction,
so your space of
parameters is not
closed under this procedure.
The same applies to all
higher dimensional systems,
and so they are not really
solvable by this approach
unless you start making
some approximations.
So the particular approximation
that I introduced here
was done and applied shortly
after Cavenaugh brought forth
this idea of removing degrees
of freedom and renormalization
by-- I'll write this
once, and hopefully I
will not make a mistake.
Niemeijer and van
Leeuwen And it's
a kind of cumulant expansion,
as I will describe shortly.
It's an approximation.
And rather than doing
the square lattice,
it is applied to the
triangular lattice.
And that's going
to be the hardest
part of this class for me,
to draw a triangular lattice.
Not doing a good job.
So basically, we put our
spins, sigma i plus minus 1,
on the sides of this.
And we put an interaction k
that operates between neighbors.
And we want to do a
renormalization in which we
reduce the number of
degrees of freedom.
What Niemeijer and van Leeuwen
suggested was the following.
You can group the
sublattices of the triangular
lattice into three.
I have indicated
them by 1, 2, 3.
Basically, there is going
to be some selection
of sublattice sites
on this lattice.
What they suggested was to
basically define cells--
so this would be one cell.
This would be another cell.
This would be another
cell over here-- such
that every side of the
original lattice belongs to one
and only one site
of these cells.
OK.
So basically, I guess the
next one would come over here.
All right.
So let's call the
site by label i.
And let's give the cells label
that I will indicate by Greek.
So sites, I will
indicate i, j, cells,
by Greek letters,
alphabet, et cetera.
So that, for example,
we can regard
this as cell alpha,
this one, this triangle,
as forming cell beta.
Now, the idea of
Niemeijer and van Leeuwen
was that to each
cell, we are going
to assign a new spin that is
reflective of the configuration
of the site spins.
So for this, they propose
the majority rule.
Basically, they said that
we call the spin for site
alpha to be the majority
of the site spins.
So basically, if all three
spins are plus or all three
of them are minus, you
basically go to plus or minus.
If two of them are plus
and one of them is minus,
you would choose the
one that is a majority.
So you can see that this also
has only two possibilities,
plus 1 and minus 1, which
would not have taken place
if I had tried to do a
majority of two sites.
It would have worked
if I had chosen
a majority of three sites
on a one-dimensional lattice
clearly.
So that's the rule.
So you can see that for every
configuration that I have
originally, I can do
these kinds of averaging
and define a configuration
that exists for the cells.
And the idea is that if I weigh
the initial configurations
according to the weight
where the nearest neighbor
coupling is k, what is
the weight that governs
these new configurations for
the averaged or majority cell
spins?
Now, to do this
problem exactly is
subject to the same difficulty
that I mentioned before.
That is, if I somehow
do an averaging
over the spins in here
to get the majority,
then I will generate
interactions
that run over further
neighboring, as we
will see shortly.
So to remove that,
they introduced a kind
of uncontrolled break-up
of the Hamiltonian
that governed the system.
That is, they wrote
beta H minus beta
H, which is the sum over
all neighboring site spins,
as the sum of a part that
then cancels perturbatively
and a part of that will treat
as a correction to the part
that we can solve exactly.
The beta H zero is this
sum over all cells alpha.
What you do is
basically you just
include the interactions
among the cell spins.
So I have K sigma alpha 1
sigma alpha 2 sigma alpha
2 sigma alpha 3 sigma
alpha 3 sigma alpha 1.
So basically, these are the
interactions within a cell.
What have I left out?
I have left out the interactions
that operate between cells,
so all of these things,
which, of course, are
the same strength but, for
lack of better things to do,
they said OK.
We are going to sum over
all, you can see now,
neighboring cells.
So the things that
I left out, let's
say, interactions between
this cell alpha and beta,
evolve-- let's say
the spin number
1 in this labeling of beta
times spin number 2 of alpha
and spin number 3 of alpha.
Now, of course, what
I call 1, 2, or 3
will depend on the relative
orientation of the neighboring
cells.
But the idea is the
same, that basically,
for each pair of
neighboring cells,
there will be two of
these interactions.
So again, these no a
priori reason to regard
this as a perturbation.
Both of them clearly carry the
same strength for the bond,
this parameter K. OK?
The justification
is only solvability.
So the partition function
that I have to calculate,
which is the sum of
all spin configuration
with the original weight, I can
write as a sum over all spin
configurations of e to the minus
beta H 0, and then minus u,
and the idea of
perturbation is, of course,
to write the part that depends
on u as a perturbation.
It's expanding the exponential.
Now, solvability
relies on the fact
that the term that
just multiplies 1
is the sum of
triplets that are only
interacting between themselves.
They don't see anybody else.
So that's clearly
very easily solvable,
and we can calculate
the partition functions
0 that describes that.
And then we can
start to evaluate
all of those other terms,
once I have pulled out
e to the minus beta H zero sum
over all configurations in Z 0.
The series that I
will generate are
averages of this
interaction calculated
with the 0 [INAUDIBLE]
Hamiltonian.
So my log of Z-- OK.
That's how if I was to calculate
the problem perturbatively.
Now I'm going to do something
that is slightly different.
So what I will do
is, rather than
do the sum that I
have indicated above,
I will do a slight variation.
I will sum only
over configurations.
Maybe I should write
it in this fashion.
I will sum only
over configurations
that under averaging give me
a particular configuration
of site spins.
So, basically, let's say I pick
a configuration in which this
is-- the cell spin is plus,
the cell spin is minus,
whatever, some
configuration of cell spins.
Now, depending on this
cell spin being plus,
there are many
configurations-- not many--
but there are four
configurations of the site
spins that would correspond
to this being plus.
There are four configurations
that would correspond to this.
So basically, I specify
what configuration of cell
spins I want, and I do this sum.
So the answer there is
some kind of a weight that
depends on my choice
of [INAUDIBLE] sigma
alpha [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
So then I have the
same thing over here.
And then, in principle,
all of these quantities
will become a function of the
choice of my configuration.
OK.
So this is a weight
for cell configurations
once I average out over all
site configurations that
are compatible with that.
So if I take the
log of this, I can
think of that as an
effective Hamiltonian that
operates on these variables.
And this is what we
have usually been
indicating by the
prime interactions.
And so, if I take the
log of that expression,
I will get log of z 0 that
is compatible with the choice
of cell spins.
And then the log
of this series--
we've seen this many times--
it starts with minus U 0
as a function of the
specified interactions.
And then I have
the variance, again
compatible with
the interactions.
OK?
So now it comes to basically
solving this problem.
And I pick some particular cell.
And I look at what
configurations
I could have that
are compactible
for a particular sign
of the cell spin.
As far as the site
spins are concerned.
And I will also
indicate what the weight
is that I have to put for that
cell coming from minus beta H0.
one thing that I
can certainly do
is to have the cell spin plus.
And I indicated that
that I can get either
by having all three
spins to be plus or just
the majority, which means
that one of the three
can become minus.
So there are these
configurations
that are consistent, all
of them, with the sigma
alpha prime, the
majority that is plus.
And there are four
configurations
that correspond to minuses we
shall obtain by essentially
flipping everything.
And the weights are
easy to figure out.
Basically I have
a triplet of spins
that are coupled by
interaction K. In this case,
all three are positive.
So I have three
into the K factor,
so I will get e to the 3K.
Whereas if one of them becomes
minus and two remain plus,
you can see that
there are two unhappy
misaligned configurations.
So I will get minus K, minus
K, plus K. I will get e
to the minus K. It doesn't
matter which one of these three
it is.
If all three are minuses, then
again, the sites are aligned.
So I will get e to the 3K.
If two minuses and 1
plus, 2 bonds are unhappy.
One is happy.
I will get e to the minus
K, e to the minus K,
e to the minus K.
So once I have specified
what my cell spin is,
the contribution to
the partition function
is obtained by summing over
contributions things that
are compatible with that.
So what is it if I specify
that my cell spin is plus?
The contribution to
the partition function
is e to the 3K plus e
to the 3 to the minus K.
It's actually exactly
the same thing
if I had specified
that it is minus.
So we see that this
factor, irrespective
of whether the choice here
is that the cell spin is
plus or minus, is log of e to
the 3K plus 3e to the minus
K. Pair any one of the cells
and how many cells I have,
1/3 of the number of sites
with the number of sites
I had indicated by N,
this would be N over 3.
OK.
Now, let's see what
this U average is.
So U-- I made one sign error.
I put both of them
as minuses, which
means that in the
notation I had-- no.
That's fine.
Minus U0.
So I put the minus sign here
-- is plus K sum over all pairs
that are neighboring
each other, for example,
like the pair alpha
beta I have indicated,
but any other pair
of neighboring cells.
I have to write an
expression such as this.
So I have the K. I have sigma.
I have beta 1 sigma alpha 2
plus sigma beta 1 sigma alpha 3.
So this is the expression
that I have for you.
I have to take the average
of this quantity, basically
the average of the sum.
I will have two
of these averages.
Now in my zero to
order weight, there
is no coupling between this
cell and any other cell.
So what the spin on
each cell is on average
cares nothing about
what the spin is
on any other cell, which
means that these averages are
independent of each other.
I can write it in this fashion.
So all I need to
do is to calculate
the average of one
of these columns,
given that I have
specified what the cell is.
So let's pick, let's say sigma
alpha 1 average in this zero
to order weight.
Now I can see
immediately that I will
have two possibilities, the
top four or the bottom four.
The top four corresponds
to sigma cell being plus.
The bottom four correspond to
the sigma cell being minus.
So the top four is
essentially I have
to look at the average
on this column.
I have-- it is either
plus, and then I
get a weight e to the 3K.
Or it is minus.
I get weight e to the minus
K plus e to the minus k plus
e to the minus k.
So once I add 2 plus
e to the minus K
and subtract 1e to the
minus K, I really get this.
Now, of course, I have to
normalize by the weights
that I have per cell.
And the weights are
really these factors
but divided by e to the
3K plus 3 to the minus K.
Whereas if I had specified
that the cell spin is minus,
and I wanted to calculate
the average here,
I would be dealing
with these numbers.
You can see that I will
have a minus e to the 3K.
I will have one plus and two
minuses e to the minus K,
so I will get minus
e to the minus K e
to the 3K plus 3e to the minus
K, which is the normalizing
weight.
So it's just minus
the other one.
And I can put these two
together and write it as e
to the 3K plus e
to the minus K e
to the 3K plus 3e to the
minus K sigma alpha prime.
So the average of any one
of these three site spins
is simply proportional to what
you said was the cell spin.
The constant of proportionality
depends on K according to this.
So now if I substitute this
over here, what do I find?
I will find that
minus U at the lowest
level, each one of these factors
will give me the same thing.
So this K becomes 2K.
I have a sum over alpha and
betas that are neighboring.
Each one of these
sigmas I will replace
by the corresponding
average here.
Add the cost of multiplying
by one of these factors.
And there are two such factors.
So I basically get this.
So add this order in the
series that I have written,
if I forget about all of those
things, what has happened?
I see that the weight that
governs the cell spins
is again something that only
couples the nearest neighbor
cells with a new interaction
that I can call K prime.
And this new
interaction, K prime,
is simply 2K into the
3K plus e to the minus K
e to the 3K plus 3 e
to the minus K squared.
So presumably, again, if I think
of the axes' possible values
of K running all the way
from no coupling at 0
to very strongly
coupling at infinity,
this tells me under rescaling
where the parameters go.
If I start here, where
do I go back and forth?
So let's follow the path that
we followed in one dimension.
We expect something
to correspond
to essentially no
coupling at all.
So we look at the limit
where K goes to 0.
Then you can see that
what is happening here
is that K prime is 2K.
And then from here, when K
goes to 0, all of these factors
become 1.
So numerator is 2,
denominator is 4.
The whole thing is squared.
So basically in that limit,
the interaction gets halved.
So if I have a very
[INAUDIBLE] coupling of 1/8,
then it becomes 1/16 and
then it becomes 1 over 32.
I get pulled towards this.
So presumably
anything that is here
will at long distance
look disordered, just
like one dimension.
But now let's look
at the other limit.
What happens when K is very
large, K goes to infinity?
Then K prime is-- well,
there's the 2K out front,
but that's it.
Because e to the 3K is going to
dominate over e to the minus K
when K is large, and
this ratio goes to 1.
So we see that if I
start with a K of 1,000,
then I go to 2,000 to
4,000, and basically I
get pulled towards a
behavior of infinity.
So this is different
from one dimension.
In one dimension, you
were always going to 0.
Now we can see that in
this two-dimensional model,
recoupling disappears,
goes to no coupling.
Strong enough coupling goes to
everybody's following in line
and doing the same
thing at large scale.
So we can very well
guess that there
should be some point
in between that
separates these
two types of flows.
And that is going to
be the point where
I would have KC,
or let's call it--
I guess I call it K
star in the notes.
So let's call it K star.
So K star is 2K star e to the 3K
star plus e to the minus K star
e to the 3K star plus e to the
minus-- 3e to the minus K star
squared.
So we can drop out the K star.
You can see that what
you have to solve
is e to the 3K star plus
e to the minus K star
divided by e to the 3K star
plus 3e to the minus K star.
This ratio is 1 over
square root of 2.
I can multiply everything
by e to the plus K star
so that this becomes 1.
And I have an algebraic equation
to solve for e to the 4K star.
So I will get root
2e to the 4K star
plus root 2 is e to
the 4K star plus 1.
And I get the value of K star,
which is 1/4 log of-- whoops,
this was a 3-- 3 minus root
2 divided by root 2 minus 1.
You put it in the
calculator, and it
becomes something that
is of the order of 0.233.
No, 27.
So yes?
AUDIENCE: So, first
thing, do we want
to name what is the length
factor by which we change
the characteristic length?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
Yes.
So the next-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: But we never kind
of bothered to do it so far.
PROFESSOR: We will
need to do immediately.
So just hold on a second.
The next thing, I
need this B factor.
But it's obvious, I have
reduced the number of degrees
of freedom by 3,
so the length scale
must have in two dimensions
increased by square root of 3.
And you can do also the
algebra analogous to this
to convince you that
the distance, let's say,
from the center of this triangle
to the center of that triangle
is exactly [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Also,
when you're writing
the cumulant expansion--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: In all of
our previous occasions
when we did perturbations,
the convergence of the series
was kind of reassured because
every perturbation was
proportional to
some scalar number
that we claimed to be
small, and thus series
would hopefully converge.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: But In this
case, how can you
be sure that for
modified interaction
and renormalized version,
you don't need [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, let me
first slightly correct
what you said before I
think you meant correctly,
which is that previously
we had parameters
that we were
ensuring were small.
That did not guarantee
the convergence
of the series or the lattice.
In this case, we don't
have even a parameter
that we can make small.
So the only thing
that we can do,
and I will briefly
mention that, is
to basically see what
happens if we include
more and more terms in that
series and we compare results
and whether there is
some convergence or not.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain again how
we got the K prime equation?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I said that I have
some configuration
of the cell spins.
Let's say the configuration
is plus plus minus plus.
Whatever, some configuration.
Now there are many
configurations of site spins
that correspond to that.
So the weight of
this configuration
is obtained by summing over the
weights of all configurations
of site spins that are
compatible with that.
And that was a series
that we had over here.
And K prime, or the
interaction, typically we
put in the exponent, so I
have to take a log of this
to see what the
interactions are.
The log has this
series that starts
with the average of
this interaction.
OK?
So this was the formula
for U. It's over here.
And then here, it says I have
to take an average of it.
Average, given that I have
specified what the cell spins
are.
And I see that that
average is really
product of averages
of site spins.
And I was able to evaluate
the average of a site spin,
and I found that up to some
proportionality constant,
it was the cell spin.
So if the cell spin is
specified to be plus,
the average of each one of the
site spins tends to be plus.
If the cell spin is
specified to be minus,
since I'm looking at this
subset of configuration,
the average is
likely to be minus.
And that proportionality
factor is here.
I put that proportionality
factor here,
and I see that this average is
a product of neighboring cell
spins, which are weighted
by this factor, which
is like the original weights
that you write, except
with a new K. Yes?
AUDIENCE: So after
renormalization,
we get some new kind of
lattice, which is not random.
It's completely new.
Because what you did here is
you take out certain cells--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And call
them [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
But what is this new lattice?
This new lattice is
a triangular lattice
that this is rotated with
respect to the original one.
So it's exactly the
same lattice as before.
It's not a random lattice.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
But on the initial
lattice, you specified
that these cells
would contribute to--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I separated K and K prime.
Yes.
K and U, yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So if you want to do a
renormalization group again,
we'll need to--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Do this.
AUDIENCE: Again [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Yeah.
But we do it once, and we
have the recursion relation.
And then we stop.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is this possible
for other odd number lattices?
Will you still
preserve the parameter?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
It's even possible
for square lattices
with some modification,
and that's
what you'll have in
one of the problems.
OK?
Fine.
But the point is-- OK.
So I stopped here.
So K star was 0.27, which is
the coupling that separates
places where you go
to uncorrelated spins,
places you go to everything
ordered together.
It turns out that the
triangular lattice is something
that one can solve exactly.
It's one of the few things.
And you'll have the pleasure
of serving that also
in a problem set.
And you will show that KC, the
correct value of the coupling,
is something like 0.33.
So that gives you an idea of how
good or bad this approximation
is.
But the point in any
case is that the location
of the coupling is
not that important.
We have discussed that
it is non-universal.
The thing that maybe we
should be more interested
in is what happens if I'm
in the vicinity of this,
how rapidly do I move away?
And actually I have to show
that we are moving away.
But because of topology,
it's more or less obvious
that it should be that way.
So what I need to do is
evaluate this at K star.
OK.
Now you can see that K
prime is a function of K.
So what you need to do
is to take derivatives.
So thers' some
algebra involved here.
And then, once you have
taken the derivative,
you have to put the
value of K star.
And here, some
calculator is necessary.
And at the end of the day, the
number that you get, I believe,
is something like 1.62.
Yes.
And so that says
since being it's
larger than 1, that you
will be pushed away.
But these things have
been important to us
as indicators of
these exponents.
In particular, I'm on the
subspace that has symmetry,
so I should be
calculating yt here.
As was pointed out,
important to this step
is knowing what the value
of B is, which we can either
look at by the ratio of
the lattice constants
or by the fact that I have
removed one third of the spins.
It has to be root
3 to the power yt.
So my yt is log of 1.62
divided by log of root 3.
So again you go and
look at your calculator,
and the answer comes
out to be 0.88.
Now the exact value of yt for
all two-dimensionalizing models
is 1.
So again, this is an
indicator of how good or bad
you have done at this
ordering perturbation tier.
OK.
Now, answering the question
that you had before,
suppose I were to go
to order of U squared?
Now, order of U
squared, I have to take
this kind of interaction,
which is bilinear.
Let's say pair of spins
here, multiply two of them,
so I will get a pair of spins
here and pair of spins there.
As long as they are
distinct locations when
I subtract the average squared,
they will subtract out.
So the only place where I
will get something non-trivial
is if I pick one
here and one here.
And by that kind
of reasoning, you
can convince yourself that
what happens at next order
is that in addition to
interactions between neighbors,
you will degenerate interactions
between things that are two
apart and things that
are, well, three apart,
so basically next
nearest neighbors
and next next nearest neighbors.
So what you will
have, even if you
start with a form
such as this, you
will generate next nearest
neighbor and next next nearest
neighbor interactions.
Let's call them K, L, M.
So to be consistent, you have
to go back to the original model
and put the three interactions
and construct recursion
relations from the
three parameters,
K, L, M, to the new
three parameters.
More or less following
this procedure,
it's several pages of algebra.
So I won't do it.
Niemeijer and van
Leeuwen did it,
and they calculated
the yt at next order
by finding the fixed point in
this three-dimensional space.
It has one relevant direction,
and that one relevant direction
gave them an eigenvalue that
was extremely close to 1.
So I don't believe anybody
has taken this to next order.
You've got good enough,
might as well stop.
I think it's not going
to improve and get better
because this is an
uncontrolled approximation.
So it's likely to be
one of those cases,
that you asymptotically
approach the good result
and then move away.
Now once I have
yt, I can naturally
calculate exponents
such as alpha.
First of all U,
which is 1 over yt.
1 over 0.88 is
something like 1.13.
And the exact result would be
the inverse of 1 which is 1.
And I can calculate alpha, which
is 2 minus d, which is 2 mu.
With that value of U,
I will get minus 0.26.
Again, the correct result
would be corresponding
to a logarithmic divergence.
So this zeroed order, OK.
Those things, let's say, for
the exponents to 10%, 20%.
You would say that, OK,
what about other exponents,
such as beta,
gamma, and so forth.
Clearly, to get those exponents,
I also need to have yh.
OK.
So to get yh, I will add, as
an additional perturbation,
a term which is h sum
over i sigma i, which
is, of course, the same thing
as sum over alpha, sigma alpha
of 1 plus sigma alpha
2 plus sigma alpha 3.
And if I regard this
as a perturbation,
you can see that in the
perturbative scheme,
this would go under
the transformation
to the average of this
quantity, and that the average
of this quantity will
give me 3 for each cell.
So I will get 3h.
And for each cell, I
will get the average
of a site spin, which is
related to the cell spin
through this factor
that we calculated,
e to the 3K e to the minus k e
to the 3k plus 3e to the minus
k sigma alpha prime.
So we can see that by
generating h prime,
which is 3h times
e to the 3K plus
e to the minus K e to the
3K plus 3e to the minus K.
And I can evaluate d
to the yh as dh prime
by dh evaluated at
the fixed point.
So I will get essentially
3 times this factor
evaluated at the fixed point.
But we can see that
at the fixed point,
this factor is 1 over root 2.
So the answer is 3 over root 2.
And my yh would be the log of 3
over root 2 divided by log of b
that we said is
square root of 3.
Put it in the calculator,
you get a number
that is of the order of 1.4.
And exact yh is 1.875.
So again, once you have yh,
you can go and calculate
through the exponent
scaling relations all
the other exponents
that you have like beta.
So not bad,
considering that if you
wanted to go through epsilon
expansion, how much difficulty
you would have.
And in any case, we
are at two dimensions,
which is far away from four.
And getting results
at 2 is worse than
trying to get results
at three dimensions.
Now we want to do the procedure
as an approximation that
is even simpler than this.
And for that-- so that was
the Niemeijer-van Leeuwen
procedure.
The next one is due to
Kadanoff again and Migdal.
And it's called bond-moving.
And again, we have to
do an approximation.
You can't do things exact.
So let's demonstrate that
by a square lattice, which
is much easier to draw than
the triangular lattice.
And let's kind of
follow the procedure
that we had for the
one-dimensional case.
Let's say we want to do
rescaling by a factor of 2.
And I want to keep this
spin, this spin, this spin,
this spin, this spin and get
rid of all of the other spins
that I have.
Not the circular
round, much as I
did for the
one-dimensional case.
And the problem is
that if I'm summing
over this spin over
here, there are
paths that connect that
spin to other spins.
So by necessity, once I sum
over all of these spins,
I will generate all
kinds of interactions.
So the problem is all of these
paths that connect things.
So maybe-- and this is
called bond-moving--
maybe I can remove all of these
things that are going to cause
problem for--
So if I do that, then
the only connection
between this spin and this
spin comes from that side,
between this spin and that
spin comes from that side.
And if the original interaction
was K and I sum over this,
I will get K prime, which is
what I have over there, 1/2 log
cos 2K, because the
only thing that I did
was to connect this
site to two neighbors,
and then effectively,
it's the same thing
as I was doing
for one dimension.
So clearly this is a
very bad approximation,
because I have reproduced
the same result
as one dimension for the
two-dimensional case.
And the reason is that
I weakened the lattice
so drastically, I removed
most of the bonds.
So there isn't that much weight
for the lattice to order.
Kadanoff and Migdal
suggested was, OK.
Let's not to remove these bonds.
Just move them to some place
that they don't cause any harm.
So I take this bond and
I strengthen this bond.
I take this bond,
strengthen this one.
This one goes to this one.
Essentially what
happens is you can
see that each one of the bonds
has been strengthened by 2.
So I have this because
of the strength.
So as simple as you can get to
construct a potential recursion
relation for this
square lattice.
So this is a way
that the parameter K
changes, going
from 0 to infinity.
And we can do the same thing
that we did over there.
So we can check that for K going
zero, if I look at K prime,
it is approximately 1/2 log of
hyperbolic cosine of something
that is close to 0.
So that becomes 1 plus the
square of this quantity, which
is 4K squared over 2.
And taking the log of that,
it becomes 4K squared.
The factor of 4 does
not really matter.
If K is very small,
like 1 over 100,
K squared would be
10 to the minus 4.
So basically, you certainly
have the expected behavior
of becoming disordered if you
have a [INAUDIBLE] interaction.
If you have a strong
enough coupling,
however, are we
different from what
we did for the
one-dimensional case?
Well, the answer is
that in this case,
K prime is 1/2 log
hyperbolic cosine of 4K,
starts as e to the 4K plus e
to the minus 4K divided by 2.
e to the minus 4K I can ignore.
So you can see that in
this case, I will have 2K.
I can even ignore the minus
log 2, which previously
was so important because
previously we had 1 here
and now it became 2, which means
that if I start to be 10,000,
it will become 20,000,
40,000 and now you're
going this direction.
So again, by necessity
almost, I must
have a fixed point at
some value in between.
So I essentially have
to solve for K star
as K star is 1/2
log cos of 4K star.
You can recast this as some
algebraic equation in terms
of e to the 4k e to the
K star and manipulate it.
And after you do
your algebra, you
will eventually come up
with a value of K star,
which I believe is 0.3.
You can ask, well, the square
lattice we will solve in class.
I said the triangular lattice
I will leave for you to solve.
KC for the square lattice
is something like 0.44.
So you are off by about 25%.
Of course, again, the quantity
that you're interested in
is b to t yt.
b is 2 in this case.
The length scale has
changed by a factor of 2,
which is dk prime by
dk evaluated as K star,
again, a combination of doing
the algebra of derivatives,
evaluating at K star, and
then ultimately taking the log
to convert it to a yt.
And you come up with a value
of yt that is around 0.75.
And, as I said, the exact
yt, which doesn't depend on
whether you are dealing
with a square lattice
or a triangular
lattice-- it's only
a function of symmetry
and dimensionality-- is 1.
So you can see that gradually we
are simplifying the complexity.
Now we could, within
this approximation,
solve everything
within one panel.
Now this kind of
approximation, again,
is not particularly very good.
But it's a quick and dirty
way of getting results.
And the advantage of it
is that you can do this
not only in two dimensions, but
in higher dimensions as well.
So let's say that you
had a cubic lattice
and you were doing rescaling
by a factor of 2, which
means that originally
you had spins along
the various diagonals
and so forth--
around the various partitions
of a square of size 2 x 2,
and you want to keep
interactions among these
and get rid of the interactions
among all of the places
that you are not interested in.
And the way that you do
that is precisely as before.
You move these interactions
and strengthen the things
that you have over here.
Now whereas the number
of bonds that you
had to move for the
square lattice was 2--
the enhancement factor
was 2-- turns out
that the enhancement factor in
three dimensions would be 4.
You essentially have to take
one from here, one from there,
one from there.
So 1 plus 3 becomes 4.
And you can convince
yourself that if I
had done this in d-dimensional
hypercubic lattice, what
I would have gotten is again
the one-dimensional recursion
relation, except for this
enhancement factor, which
is 2 to the power of d
minus 1 in d dimensions.
Actually, I could even do
that for rescaling rather
by a factor 2, by a factor of b.
And hopefully, you
can convince yourself
that it will become b to
the d minus 1 times 2K.
And essentially that
factor is a cross section
that you have to remove.
So the cross-sectional area that
you encounter grows as the size
to the power of d minus 1.
And a kind of obvious
consequence of that
is that if I go to the limit
of K going to infinity,
you can see that K prime b would
go like b to the d minus 1K.
Essentially, if you were to
have some kind of a system
and you make pluses on one
side, minuses on the one side,
to break it, then,
the number of bonds
that you would
have to break would
grow like the
cross-sectional area.
So that's where that comes from.
It turns out that, again,
this approach is exact
as we've seen for one dimension.
As we go to higher dimensions,
it becomes worse and worse.
So I showed you how bad
it was in two dimensions.
If I calculate the fixed point
and the exponents in three
dimensions compared to our best
numerical result, it is off by,
I don't know, 40%, 50%,
whereas 25% over there.
So it gradually gets
worse and worse.
And so one approach that
people have tried to do,
which, again, doesn't
seem to be very rigorous
is to convert this into an
expansion on dimensionality
of 1.
So it's roughly
correct that it's
going to be close to 1--
correct close to one dimension.
But as opposed to the
previous epsilon expansion,
there doesn't seem to be a
controlled way to do this.
I showed you how to do
this for Ising models.
Actually, you can do
this for any spin model.
So let's imagine that we have
some kind of a model that's
in one dimension.
At each site, we
have some variable
that as i that I will
not specify what it is,
how many variables-- how
many values it takes.
But it interacts only with
its neighboring sites.
And so presumably, there
is some interaction
that depends on the two sites.
There may be multiple
couplings implicit in this
if I try to write this in terms
of the dot product of spins
or things like this.
So if I were to calculate
the partition function in one
dimension-- I already
mentioned this last time--
I have to do a sum
over what this spin is
of e to the K of si si
plus 1 and a product
over subsequent sites.
And if I regard this as a
matrix, which is generally
called a transfer
matrix, you can
see that this
multiplication involving
the sum over all of the
spins is equivalent to matrix
multiplication.
And, in particular, if I have
periodic boundary conditions
in which the last spin
couples to the first spin,
I would have trace of
T to the power of N,
where t is essentially this,
e to the K of si si plus 1.
Now, clearly I can
write this as trace of T
squared to the
power of N over 2.
Right.
And this I can regard as
the partition function
of a system that has
half as many spins.
So I have performed the
renormalization group
like what we are doing
in one dimension.
I have T prime is T squared.
And in general, you can see
that I can write this as N
to the b N over b.
So the result of
renormalization by a factor of b
is simply one dimension to
take the matrix that you have
and raise it to b power.
OK.
And so I could parameterize my
T by a set of interactions K,
like we do for the Ising model.
Raise it to the power of b,
and I would generate the matrix
that I could then
parametrize by K prime,
and I would have the
relationship between K prime
and K in one dimension.
So this is d equals 1.
And the way to generalize
this Migdal Kadanoff, RG,
to a very general
system is simply
to enhance the couplings.
So basically, what
I would write down
is T prime, which, after
rescaling by a factor of b,
is a function of a set of
parameters that I will K prime,
is obtained by taking the
matrix that I have for one set
of couplings and raise
it to the power of b.
This is the exact
one-dimensional result.
And if I want to construct this
approximation in d dimensions,
I will just do this.
So for a while, before people
had sufficiently powerful
computers to maybe
simulate things as easily,
this was a good way to estimate
locations and exponents
of phase diagrams,
critical exponents,
et cetera for essentially
complicated problems
that could have a set
of parameters even here.
Nowadays, as I
said, you probably
can do things much more easily
by computer simulations.
So I guess I still have
another 10 minutes.
I probably don't want
to start on the topic
of the next lecture.
But maybe what I'll do is
I'll expand a little bit
on something that I mentioned
very rapidly last lecture,
which is that in this
one-dimensional model where
I solve the problem by
transfer matrix, what I have is
that the partition function
is trace of some matrix raised
to the N power.
And if I diagonalize the
matrix, what I will get
is the sum over all eigenvalues
raised to the N power.
Now note that we expect
phase transitions to occur,
not for any finite system,
but only in the limit where
there are many
degrees of freedom.
And, actually, if
I have such a sum
as this in the limit of
very large number of degrees
of freedom, this becomes
lambda max to the power of N.
Now in order to get any one of
these series of eigenvalues,
what should I do?
I should take a matrix,
which is this e to the T--
e to the strength
of the interactions.
What did I write? e to
the K of S and S prime.
So there is a matrix.
All of its elements
are Boltzmann weights.
There are all positive.
And find the eigenvalues
of this matrix.
Now for the case of the Ising
model without a magnetic field,
the matrix is 2 x 2.
It's e to the K, corresponding
to the diagonal terms
where the spins are
parallel, e to the minus K
when the spins are antiparallel.
And clearly you can see that the
eigenvalues corresponding to 1,
1 or 1, minus 1 as eigenvectors,
are hyperbolic cosine of K--
strike this.
e to the K plus e to the
minus K e to the K minus
e to the minus K. You
can see that to get this,
all I had to do was to
diagonalize a matrix that
corresponded to one
bond, if you like.
And just as in here,
there is no reason
to expect that these
eigenvalues, which
depend on this
set of parameters,
should non-analytical functions.
There is no reason
for non-analyticity
as long as you are dealing
with a single bond.
We expect non-analyticities
at their limit of large N.
So if each one of these
is analytic function of K,
the only way spanning the K
axis that I could encounter
in non-analyticity is if two
of these eigenvalues cross,
because we have seen a
potential mechanism for phase
transitions.
We discussed this in A333.
That if we have sum
of contributions,
that each one of them is
exponentially large in N,
and two of these
contributions cross,
then your partition function
will jump from one hill
to another hill.
And you will have a
discontinuity, let's say,
in derivatives or whatever.
So the potential
mechanism that I can have
is that if I have as
a function of changing
one of my parameters or a
bunch of these parameters,
the ordering of
these eigenvalues--
let's say lambda 0 is
the largest one, lambda
1 is the next one,
lambda 2, et cetera.
So each one of them
is going its own way.
If the largest one suddenly
gets crossed by something else,
then you willl basically abandon
one eigenvalue for another,
and you will have a mechanism
for a phase transition.
So what I told you was that
there is a theorem that
for a matrix where all of
the eigenvalues are positive,
this will never happen.
The largest eigenvalue
will remain non-degenerate.
And there is some
analog of this,
probably you've seen
in quantum mechanics,
that if you have a
potential, the ground
state is non-degenerate.
The ground state is
always a function
that is positive everywhere.
And the next
excitation would have
to have a node go
from plus to minus.
And somehow you cannot
have the eigenvalues cross.
So in a similar sense, it turns
out the largest eigenvalue,
the largest eigenvector
for these matrices,
will have all of the
elements positive,
and it cannot become degenerate.
And so you are guaranteed
that this will not happen.
Now the second part of
this story that I briefly
mentioned was you can repeat
this for two dimensions,
for three dimensions,
higher dimensional things.
So one thing that
you could do is,
rather than sorting the
Ising model on a line,
you can solve it on a ladder,
or a ladder that has two rungs.
So solving the Ising
model on this structure
is not very
difficult because you
can say that there are eight
possible values that this
can take.
And so I can construct
a matrix that
is 8 x 8 that tells me how I
go from the choice of eight
possibilities here to the
eight possibilities there.
And I will have an 8 x 8 matrix
that has these properties
and will satisfy this.
It will be true if
I go to a 4 strip.
It will be a 16 x 16.
No problem.
I can keep going.
And it would say, well,
the two-dimensional--
and also you could do
three-dimensional or higher
dimensional models-- should
not have a phase transition.
Well, it turns out
that all of this
relies on having
a finite matrix.
And what Onsager showed
was that, indeed,
for any finite strip, you
would have a situation
such as this-- actually
more accurately
if I were to draw a
situation such as this, where
two eigenvalues would
approach but will never cross.
And one can show that
the gap between them
will scale as something
like 1 over this length.
And so in the limit where you
go to a large enough system,
you have the
possibility of ascension
to some singularity when two
eigenvalues touch each other.
So this scenario is very
well known and studied
in two dimensions.
In higher dimensions,
we actually
don't really know what happens.
OK.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: So it appears that
there are or there are not
phase transitions [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, we
showed-- we were discussing
phase transitions for
the triangular lattice,
for the square lattice.
I even told you what the
critical coupling is.
AUDIENCE: But it seems to me
that the conclusion of what
you're-- of this part
is that there aren't.
PROFESSOR: As long as you
have a finite strip, no.
But if you have a 2-- an
infinite strip, you do.
So what I've shown you
here is the following.
If I have an L x N system
in which you keep L finite
and set N going to infinity,
you won't see a singularity.
But if I have an N x N system,
and I said N goes to infinity,
I will encounter a
singularity in the limit
of N going to infinity.
Again, very roughly,
one can also
should develop a physical
picture of what's going on.
So let's imagine that
you have a system that
is a very large number but
finite in one direction.
And this other direction can
be two, can be three, whatever.
You have a finite size.
But in this other
direction, you basically
can go as large as you like.
Now presumably this
two-dimensional model
has a phase transition if
it was infinite x infinite.
And on approaching
that phase transition,
there would be a
correlation length
that would diverge
with this exponent nu.
So let's say I am sufficiently
far away from the phase
transition that the correlation
length is something like this.
So this patch of spins
knows about each other.
If I go closer to
the transition,
it will grow bigger and bigger.
At some point, it will fit
the size of the system,
and then it cannot
grow any further.
So beyond that,
what you will see
is essentially
there is one patch
here, one patch
here, one patch here.
And you are back to a
one-dimensional system.
So what happens is that
your correlation length
starts to grow as if you were
in two dimensions or three
dimensions.
Once it hits the
size of the system,
then it has to saturate.
It cannot grow any bigger.
And then this block becomes
independent of the next block.
So essentially, you would say
that you would have effectively
a one-dimensional system where
the number of blocks that you
have is of the
order of N over L.
So what we are going to do
starting from next lecture
is to develop again a more
systematic approach, which
is a series expansion about
either low temperatures
or more usefully about
high temperature.
And then we will take that
high temperature expansion
and gradually go
in the direction
to solve these
two-dimensionalizing models
exactly.
And so we will
see why I told you
some of these results
about exact value of KC,
exact value yT.
Where do they come from?